welcome back the woman tried twice and
eventually convicted of being involved
in a complicated murder-for-hire plot
could be a witness for the State of
Florida in another trial Catherine
mcbandoah was found guilty of being the
go-between in the planning of the murder
of Dan Markell Markell was an FSU
professor in Tallahassee before his
death Marquette was involved in a
custody dispute with his ex-wife Wendy
Adelson her brother Charlie Adelson is
also accused of being involved in the
murder he set to go to trial in the New
Year Mack banwa was transported from
prison on Wednesday to give a statement
to the prosecution but what exactly she
said or what it could mean for Meg
banuel's life sentence in prison is
unknown
Terry this case has impacted a lot of
people you spoke with Ruth Markell Dan
markell's mother what was she able to
share with you well Brian I have to say
that Ruth Markell is one of the
strongest survivors I have ever seen she
lost her son in that violent Ambush back
in 2014 and the trials of those involved
are still ongoing the tragedy in all
this is that Ruth was not able to see
her grandchildren for years Wendy took
them to South Florida shortly after
Dan's murder Ruth has been fighting for
the right to see her grandchildren since
that time and those efforts were finally
rewarded when she was instrumental in
passing What's called the Markell act
Governor DeSantis signed that bill this
past June it will protect grandparents
and grandchildren against alienation
from each other in these types of really
tragic situations fortunately the two
men at the scene of the crime are both
behind bars but as part of Rivera's plea
deal he was only able to serve seven
years for his participation and a lot of
people had a problem with that Garcia
however will serve the rest of his
natural life in prison but Catherine
mcbanwa seems to be the linchpin in this
crime she allegedly connected the two
killers to the adelsons the
prosecution's theory is that Wendy
Adelson her brother Charlie and her
parents all wanted Dan killed over a
simple custody battle for the two boys I
asked Ruth about her thoughts on what
mcbanwa might have to say in this
upcoming hearing listen to what Ruth
told me
now what we do know is that um if she
has new evidence it'll have to be backed
up so I'm you know very uh interested
excited about this opportunity but she
already
um testified on the stand twice right
and this whatever she's going to talk
about now is going to be contradictory
to what she said before and it depends
on how the prosecutor takes that
information in terms of the quality of
the new information
measured against her past testimonies
and then it would have to be
corroborated this is really important
because she can come and say yes I saw
this I did this but they can't accept
this now after she previously I don't
want to use the word lied but let's just
say she suddenly wants to change her
testimony and and so forth so I think
the New Evidence is has to be very very
strong and it probably could be
something related to the bump it can
something be related to her employment
because she has info information around
those periods of time which are very
valuable
you know for Ruth's sake and for the
sake of the entire Markel family let's
hope that mcbanwa can shine light on
this crime and ensure that all the
parties involved will be held
accountable
Dina what's a proper and why would
McDonald testify she's already been
sentenced to life
essentially what a proper is is a
witness is giving testimony and then
whether or not it's at trial or here
before trial to determine what will
happen in this case the prosecutors are
probably trying to figure out how good
is the evidence that she could later
testify in trial about is it worth
giving her some sort of deal as you
mentioned she's already been sentenced
but it's impossible for the prosecution
to request a reduction in her sentence
and perhaps they might if the testimony
is that good all right we'll see how
that pans out for her testimony of
course the proper thank you both it was
one year ago that 18 year old Kyle
reinhaus was found not guilty for
killing two men and seriously injuring a
third in Kenosha Wisconsin but now in an
exclusive interview for an upcoming
two-hour documentary produced by law and
crime Productions the prosecution in the
case Thomas Binger says he believes
Rittenhouse is guilty
I think that he's guilty I think that
this is behavior that we cannot tolerate
I don't believe that this is Justified
self-defense it is the principle that we
stood for in this case a 17 year old
running around our streets with an AR-15
killing unarmed people is absolutely
unacceptable and I'm not backing down
from that position at all
in the same documentary calran house
says the jury verdict proves he did
nothing wrong
a jury proved I didn't murder anybody I
acted in lawful self-defense the trial
proved I wasn't a white supremacist I
don't believe in what white supremacists
believe in I think it's disgusting and I
think it's hateful
since the vertigrainian house has
emerged as a hero to the right and
become an advocate for second amendment
rights groups